We'll be joined
by celebrity expert judge,
Lance Bass, Lance Bass,
Lance Bass, Lance Bass.
Oh my God, oh my God,
oh my God, oh my God.
Let's go.
This week on "Squad Wars",
we're at a professional
sound stage
- in Southern California.
- Okay, this is it,
- let's get playback.
- We're about to blow your mind.
Two amazing squads each paired
with one of us compete to face
the music and get NSYNC
with the goal
to become the ultimate boy band.
Now get ready to dance
Eugene's off.
In the end, they will be judged
and only one will win
the most coveted
reality show award ever,
the Tryphy.
Cue music.
♪♪
Welcome to "Squad Wars",
where you'll never have
to pick a fight
because we pick it for you.
Think of us
as your battle baristas
serving up hot competition.
What is this voice
that we're doing?
- Don't worry about it.
- Okay.
Well, we're the Try Guys
and each week
we challenge two squads
to a competition
unlike they've ever seen before.
Eugene and I
will be your hosts for today,
which means Zach and Ned
will be joining the squads.
Zach, who will be
your chums for the day?
Guys, I am so excited.
We have joining us the cast
from one of the greatest movies
of our, nay,
any generation.
From "Hook",
we have the Lost Boys.
I'm talking about Jimmy Madio,
Ahmad Stoner, and Dante Basco,
aka Don't ask,
No Nap, and Rufio.
What's, up Try Guys?
We shot a move years ago
but we hung out our whole lives,
so I have no doubt that
we're gonna work well together.
Once a Lost Boy,
always a Lost Boy.
The crow call is iconic.
Can you--can you just
teach it to me?
You can fly, you can fight,
and you could [makes noise]
[makes noise]
- There it is.
- That just gave me
the biggest nostalgia boner.
So Ned, do you finally
have a squad
you can talk to about marriage
and stuff with?
Yes, it's very exciting, Eugene.
I'm here with three stars
from "The Bachelor".
Please Welcome Jake Pavelka,
Kiptyn Locke, and Caila Quinn.
I am stoked to be here today
with Jake and Caila.
Our squad is gonna bring
the energy.
So you three are bachelors,
I'm married,
will that be an issue?
You could give us
some tips, right?
I'm honored, of course.
Zach? Ned?
Please join your squads.
Yeah.
We're going Big Try today.
You're gonna be choreographing
and lipsyncing
in your very own '90s
boy band music video.
- What?
- That's my worst nightmare
because I'm useless
when it comes to dancing.
Boy bands
are the ultimate squads
and their videos
are the ultimate showcase
- of their skills.
- So for a little inspiration,
we're gonna be beaming in
one of the all-time
great boy band members
from NSYNC.
That's right,
our in-studio expert
will be none other than
Lance Bass.
- Shut up.
- Lance Bass?
Oh my God, oh my God,
oh my God, oh my God.
What's going on, Try Guys?
He knows our name.
- Hello, squads.
- Hey, Lance.
You're gonna have one day
to go from newbies
to heartthrobs.
Now, once your videos are done,
we're gonna be
judging you on personality
and performance.
As well as the heart, passion,
and overall squad work
that you bring to the Big Try.
I'll see you soon and good luck.
Thank you, Lance.
Let's do it.
Your videos have to achieve
the classic boy band look,
dancing and lip syncing
to the music.
- Good luck.
- You can do it.
- That's awesome.
Eugene will be demonstrating
some boy band
inspired dance moves.
It will be your job to copy him.
Mess up and you'll be out faster
than Zayn left One Direction.
- Oh.
- Ooh.
The squad with at least
one member left
- standing will win.
- By winning the Mini Try,
you will have an advantage
in the Big Try.
You will be able
to choose your props
for your music video first.
- All right.
- Yeah. We got this, guys.
- We got this.
- Last man standing.
After he teaches,
I start eliminating.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
The first choreography
is pretty easy.
When Eugene turned around
and faced us,
it got tougher for me
and I completely lost my mind.
All right, that's enough review,
I want to see the performance.
Get ready to dance
your jeans off.
Jimmy, it ain't no lie, baby.
Bye, bye, bye.
- Get out, Jimmy.
- It's gonna be a long day--
- Get out.
- --for me, dude.
- All right.
- ♪ Now you heard it ♪
♪ All before ♪
♪ And can't take no more ♪
I saw a little misstep
from one of our own, Ned.
- What?
- This is not a democracy.
- This is a Keithtatorship.
- This is...
- Don't you dare touch me.
- Bullcrap.
Don't you dare touch me.
- This is Bullcrap.
Get out of here.
We are tied at three each.
Let's get to it.
♪ I'll do anything ♪
♪ To stop you walking away ♪
- Kiptyn, you're gone.
Get out of there.
- Dude, there's no way.
- Gone, goodbye.
Again, I want to see it again.
♪ Don't walk away ♪
Sorry Zach,
you're gone over there.
- (BLEEP)
Also Jake, you're out of there.
I don't know if I was hiding
behind somebody
but I don't think I got it once
and I should've been
the first one off
to be honest with you.
Jake, what happened?
- Jake, Zach goodbye.
It's down to two against one.
♪ I want you to stay ♪
Ahmad, you're gone,
get out of there.
- Final showdown.
- ♪ Never will make you cry ♪
♪ Even though you must go ♪
♪ Whoa ♪
♪ Baby, please say no to go ♪
Caila, no.
Boo, you're out.
The winner of the Mini Try
is Rufio.
Yes.
Come on, Lost Boys, come on.
- Yes.
- Congratulations
to the Lost Boys Squad.
It's time to start your training
for the Big Try.
And Keith has written a song
especially for you today.
Yes, it is called Love 4 Men
and I'm counting on both of you
to make it a massive viral hit.
I want to be writing
for Katy Perry after this
or at least Tyler Perry,
some Perry.
And Eugene will be
your dance instructor
for the day, so learn quick.
Let's do this.
First things first,
you've got to hear the song.
Start thinking about what--
how it speaks to you.
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
- ♪ Yeah ♪
- The lyrics are so adorable,
are you kidding me?
I want some man
to sing that to me.
♪ For you to love four men ♪
Here are the lyrics
to your song.
I'm trying to learn
these lyrics,
it's just not clicking
for some reason
and I'm hoping it all
comes together in the end.
Boy bands have four main roles.
We have the heartthrob,
we have the bad boy,
we have the clown,
the person who's happy.
And then we have the cutie.
- I'll do the bad boy.
- Are you the heartthrob--
you're the bad boy?
You're taking the bad boy?
I seen him punch people.
Oh, goodness.
That's a bad boy right there.
I've always been friendzoned
- because I'm cute.
- So we have heartthrob.
Clearly if you're the leader
of the Lost Boys,
you got to be the leader
of the Lost Boys boy band.
So that makes me the clown.
Hey, the clown is good.
Like, I wanna see--
give me a smile.
Yeah, that's it.
Oh, okay.
I feel like I'm mostly the cutie
for most part.
- You're the cutie.
- Okay.
I think Jake's always been
a heartthrob.
If you go there,
I'll go bad boy.
- Are you good with that?
- That leaves me--
- It's a plan, it's a plan.
- --as the clown.
I think the clown
is fitting for you.
You got big red shoes already.
- Yeah.
- Perfect.
You know, today, we're not just
Lost Boys anymore,
we're Lost Men.
We're Lost Boys to Men.
I think ultimately with us,
you know,
we're actors, so we can bring in
the character work.
All right, guys.
Get out there, get to dancing,
go on, put it in your body.
What?
The music. Put it in your body.
- Reconsider that one.
- What's confusing
about put it in your body?
Dating Squad.
Right now, we are gonna develop
some choreography
and group performance moves.
This is Boy Band 101,
welcome to class.
You wanna get close enough
so that they can get
that effect, oh,
I'm like right here
- in your face, girl.
- Right.
Yo, I'm like right here
in your face, girl.
Exactly, there we go, Ned.
This is hilarious.
The heartthrob sings,
we got our wandering happening.
Cutie, so you can always go
straight back
and they'll come back in.
And the heartthrob
- one more time.
- ♪ Open your eyes ♪
So the choreography
is a little bit easier
than the lyrics, I don't know
about stringing
both of them together,
that's really gonna be hard.
So Ned, you have to remember
that line.
Better get in line faster.
Now.
Let's start with the bad boy
over here.
Maybe hit a pose.
Let's see the heartthrob.
Let's see the cutie.
- Make me laugh, Zach.
- Pose.
Surprise, surprise,
Eugene's being bossy as hell.
- Cute, stand up.
- Ow.
I love you, I love you.
♪ I still love you ♪
And cross Jimmy.
This is really advanced stuff.
Our spacing is off,
we're bumping into each other.
My only hope is that
Dating Squad is all as good
as dancers as Ned is.
Which is bad,
Ned's a really bad dancer.
[thud]
- Oh, Okay.
See? I told you Ned
was terrible at dancing.
We've learned
our character work,
we've obviously crushed
the choreography.
Now it's time to boogey on down,
film the scenes
that are gonna make up
our music video.
All right, Lost Boys Squad
you have won the Mini Try.
- Yes.
Which means you get first choice
in your props.
Have at it, get your props.
- Let's do it.
- All right.
The drum, the sand castle,
maybe these.
Do we wanna play
with these giant balls yet or--
Yeah, we'll deal
with the balls later.
Great.
We're at a little bit
of a disadvantage
because we didn't get to pick
our props first
but we've got some
of the biggest heartthrobs
and we've got Ned.
Let's get pumped,
let's get pumped,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Squad, squad--
- Squad, squad,
squad, squad, squad,
squad, squad.
- Are we ready?
- Yeah, playback.
All right.
Let's get playback, please.
Right now remember
just be having fun, you know?
Some scenes.
What's going on here?
We got to do--what are you--
what are you doing?
Zach, in his past life,
he really, really,
wanted to be in a boy band
because when he went for it,
it was scary.
Like, he really,
really went for it.
Get close up and just start
noshing on those fish.
Oh. Oh, God.
I think we got it.
[cough]
Why'd you make me bite
that plastic fish?
Don't worry about it
[indistinct]
let's get out of here,
great work.
Cue music.
♪ I love you ♪
It's all about the B roll.
That's where you come alive
as a squad,
that's where you really
distinguish yourself
as characters.
Oh cute, yeah, there we go.
Honestly, the beach scene
was a little unorganized
but the closer,
the slow mo pillow fight,
that's gonna be victory lane.
- That was an amazing shot.
- Thank you.
Think about your parts,
think about
- the emotion you have, okay?
- Yeah, okay.
Most importantly,
it's about having fun together.
Boy bands are best friends.
Remember, faces.
Yeah, yeah.
In the close ups, it's important
to nail the lip syncing.
I'm looking around
and we really look
- like a boy band.
- I love the love in your eyes.
♪ I love the love in your eyes ♪
But we're not a real boy band,
so Keith has to keep feeding us
every line.
When we go out on a date.
♪ When we go out on a date ♪
♪ We pick you up in a bus ♪
- ♪ No, it's not-- ♪
- Get in there, Ned.
- ♪ --polygamy ♪
- ♪ Girl, we're polygam-us ♪
Are you ready? You're ready.
Everyone's ready? Okay.
This is it, let's get playback.
Look, my squad,
we're not reality show models.
So in our close up,
we're gonna bring the energy,
we're gonna bring the fun,
we're gonna drizzle you
with dazzle.
You're gonna be
drowning in dazzle.
♪ No it's not polygamy ♪
♪ Girl, we're polygamy-us ♪
- Come on.
- ♪ I got to say ♪
♪ I can't see it any other way ♪
Get hyped, yeah.
♪ Lying on the beach,
sharing ceviche ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ I wanna love you four ways ♪
That was it, that was it.
That was it, man.
You crushed it.
You know, the one thing
that you guys might have
over Lost Boys Squad
is a little more sexuality.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
So really make love
to that camera.
- Yeah?
- Make the cameramen (BLEEP)
Yeah.
Sorry. Sorry cam-
Sorry, guys. Okay.
That was gross.
All right, never mind
but you know what I mean.
Okay. Go.
Sexy walk.
Very sexy, yes.
The biggest strength we have
as a squad
is that we all are masters
of love.
We've been on The Bachelor,
The Bachelorette
and so we know what it's like
to, you know,
flirt with an audience
and flirt with each other
and I think that's our strength.
Look in that camera
and down, Jake.
Great, very sexy.
Go, yeah.
Right up in that lens.
Oh.
We're shooting the choreography
and we are still
not getting this down.
We are running out of takes
but we can't stop messing up.
Look, if we don't nail this,
we don't have a chance
of winning this episode.
And if we don't win
this episode,
I don't win a single episode
in "Squad Wars".
And then I have to go home
and tell my parents
that I got a YouTube Red show
and didn't win
a goddamn episode.
Last time with this
low angle camera.
So get up in its face.
This is our last shot,
I feel like it's only right.
Dante, can you give us
a pump up speech?
We're gonna bring it back
to Neverland one time,
- one time for Robin.
- One time for Robin.
One time for Robin
on the bangarang.
On three.
One, two, three.
Bangarang.
Cue the music.
We really pulled together.
I think it worked,
I hope it worked.
With the videos in the can,
it's time to take our squads
back to the Squad Wars studio.
And an extra special thanks
to our two experts today,
myself and Gene.
- Who's Gene?
- Eu-gene.
Oh.
Okay. So we were just
in a sound stage
in Hollywood, now we're
at the Squad War studios,
blah, blah, blah,
boring, boring.
Who needs exposition
when you got Lance Bass
Lancey-B!
Could you tell us
about life as a pop star,
what was that like?
Ugh, it was just hell.
Hell on the road.
No, are you kidding me?
It was incredible.
We were teenagers
traveling the world
with your best friends.
Always, you know,
playing jokes on each other.
I thank God there
was no social medial back then
because we probably would've
been in a lot of trouble.
A quick reminder to both squads
that we'll be judging you today
on performance, personality.
Not to mention the overall
heart, passion,
and squad work
that you brought to--
The Big Try.
All right,
that's plenty of exposition,
Lance Bass is here.
So let's go ahead
and get to watching
Lost Boys Squad
first ever music video,
Love 4 Men.
Hey girl,
this is the Lost Boys,
we're all grown up now.
This is Rufio, Don't Ask,
No Nap, and Zach.
And we're fulfilling
all your dreams,
we're taking you back to
Neverland.
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
- ♪ Yeah ♪
- ♪ We all love you ♪
♪ And we'd like
to offer the chance ♪
♪ For you to love four men ♪
♪ Girl, we love you ♪
♪ With all of our hearts ♪
♪ We take four bullets for you ♪
♪ And we all have
our favorite parts ♪
♪ I love the love in your eyes ♪
♪ I wanna hold you all night ♪
♪ I love the smile
on your face ♪
♪ I love to share you
four ways ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
♪ When we go out on a date ♪
♪ We'll pick you up in a bus ♪
♪ No, it's not polygamy ♪
♪ Girl, we're polygam-us ♪
♪ I've got to say
I can't see it any other way ♪
♪ You and I and Mark
and Tim and Blake ♪
♪ All lying on the beach,
sharing ceviche ♪
♪ Hey, we wanna love you
four ways ♪
♪ We are four times the man ♪
♪ Of any other man ♪
♪ And we end every night ♪
♪ With us all holding hands ♪
- ♪ Holding hands ♪
- ♪ We'd save so much ♪
♪ On a family
cellular plan ♪
♪ When you choose love four
men ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you, yeah ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
♪ Won't you love four men? ♪
So Lost Boys Squad,
what do you think
about the video?
It was interesting.
I would like to know
how was it
for y'all to make
this music video?
I had a difficult time
with the dancing,
it was definitely no secret.
So you were the Lance
of the group, then?
I guess, maybe. Maybe.
Next up, Dating Squad's
version of Love 4 Men.
Girl, you love one man.
Can you handle two more?
And a girl?
We're about to blow your mind.
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
- ♪ Yeah ♪
- ♪ We all love you ♪
♪ And we'd like
to offer the chance ♪
♪ For you to love four men ♪
♪ Girl, we love you ♪
♪ With all of our hearts ♪
♪ We take four bullets for you ♪
♪ And we all have
our favorite part ♪
♪ I love the love in your eyes ♪
♪ I wanna hold you all night ♪
♪ I love the smile
on your face ♪
♪ I love to share
you four ways ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
♪ When we go out on a date ♪
♪ We'll pick you up in a bus ♪
♪ No, no it's not polygamy ♪
♪ Girl, we're polygam-us ♪
♪ I've got to say
I can't see it any other way ♪
♪ You and I and Mark
and Tim and Blake ♪
♪ All lying on a beach
sharing ceviche ♪
♪ Hey, we wanna love you
four ways ♪
♪ We are four times the man ♪
♪ Of any other man ♪
♪ And we end every night ♪
♪ With us all holding hands ♪
- ♪ Holding hands ♪
- ♪ We'd save so much ♪
♪ On a family
cellular plan ♪
♪ When you choose
to love four men ♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ I also love you, yeah ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
♪ Won't you love four men? ♪
- Woo!
Dating Squad,
what do you think?
Dude, I got sweaty.
I say we start voting
on the individual categories.
Dating Squad,
how do you feel like you did
in the personality department?
We're not actors, you know,
so it's more real, in reality.
For our heartthrobs,
I'd go home with him
at a bar but I think
you got me pregnant.
- Damn.
- Kind of agree with you here.
You definitely give me
the Nick Lachey heartthrob
but Dante here,
he appeals to all the ladies,
the sensitive heartthrob,
and I think that goes
a little further
with the ladies out there, so--
So he'll get you pregnant
and help you raise it.
Yeah.
You know,
I wanna jump to the cutie.
You were incredibly cute
but there's no comparison.
Like, you blew us away.
That putting
that heart together,
I mean, I think
the whole world melted.
Going to the bad boys.
Well, stylized,
I think Jimmy
might have won this one.
Also, I love it
when a good bad boy
- gets that stomach out.
- Oh, yes he did--
he did give a lot of skin.
Your stomach is better
than mine.
Or you can just not wear a shirt
and not need to do that.
Oh.
- Shots fired.
- He got shade.
- That was shade.
- Shots fired.
And finally, the clown.
I'll let you guys
battle it out.
Well, what's there to battle?
I was a funnier clown.
You were like a homeless person.
I know for a fact Joey Fatone
wore that outfit once.
- Lance, back me up here.
- I mean, he probably did, yeah.
It's very similar, yeah.
I know for a fact people wore
their ties
around their heads in the '90s.
Lance, back me up here.
If it was bedazzled,
I think it will be really good.
I love the both of you
just keep trying
to get Lance.
Because his is the only vote
that matters.
Let's go ahead and do our vote
on personality.
Now Lost Boys, I feel like,
especially your look,
I could get any still
from that video
and I can just go
one, two, three, four, done.
Very simple, Lost Boys Squad.
Obviously, I got pregnant
by one group,
which was amazing.
The Lost Boys Squad.
- Oh, no.
- What?
It was all in the style
and that's what edged
The Lost Boys into winning
this category.
We got the Lance vote.
As we move
into the next category.
Performance.
Let's start over here
with The Lost Boys.
I think our performance
really benefited
from each other's energy,
you know,
we wanted to make it feel
like a really fun time.
A lot of my footage,
I just--I made--a nightmare.
- A buffoon.
- Yes, that's the perfect word.
- I was a--
- Nincompoop.
Sure. I mean, we could stop
with the insults.
- I think buffoon is fine.
- Idiot.
- No, I...
- Ignoramus.
Yeah. Lance, it hurts more
hearing it from you.
So let's talk about you guys.
How do you feel
your performance was
in your music video?
Our choreography looked
more difficult,
not always a good thing
but, you know,
we threw it out there
and, well, I think we nailed it.
I think our chorus
was more memorable,
I--looking back on it,
I'm not quite sure
what their course
was other than, like, thrusting.
- You remembered it.
- Nailed it.
- There you go.
- Apparently, very memorable.
I think it's time to vote
for performance.
Again, both of these performance
were really good.
So good, that you guys
blew the (BLEEP)
roof off this place.
You didn't pay
the electric bill.
(BLEEP) we can't use any of this
so I can swear
as much as I (BLEEP)
- We good?
- We're good, we're rolling.
So we were just about to vote
on the performance
and all the lights
in the studio went out.
So we've got some
great new lights,
they're incredibly harsh.
- Yeah.
- Everybody looks okay.
- Beautifully lit by...
- Lamps Bass.
Lamps Bass Incorporated.
So performance.
Lost Boys, I thought you did
a really great job.
You were also incredible,
Dating Squad.
When you got it down,
it was so expressive
and it was so on
and you guys at least
got it really good once
and that's kind of what matters.
Like I say,
it's always how you finish.
And for that, I got to give it
over to my Dating Squad.
I think Lost Boys
sometimes felt like
you were parodying everything
as opposed to the Dating Squad
which was authentically
trying to live
in those performances.
So I have to give this one
- to Dating Squad.
- It's up to Lance, I guess.
I'm going to have to go
with the Dating Squad.
All right.
Oh, my God.
That's awesome.
But what really matters
is the overall
heart, passion, and squad work
that you brought to the Big Try
and for that,
we're gonna need to deliberate
together without you
all involved.
So if you would please
reach under you seat
and grab the noise
canceling headphones
and pop those on those noggins.
Obviously, we're split here,
you know.
We have great performance,
great character.
The challenge was to make
a boy band music video.
- Mm-Hmm.
And right now,
I think we lean this way
to Dating Squad
because their video--
- Magic happened.
- It was magic.
But in terms of the NSYNCness
I think Lost Boys Squad
was way more together.
And like you said, you know,
when you pause that video
which one
is the Great American Boy Band
and there's one
of those groups right now
that I could say I would think
is the Great American Boy Band.
Sounds like we're all
in agreement here.
Are we ready to make
our decision?
- Yes.
- You could say that we are...
- NSYNC.
- Yes.
Why don't we have our squads
remove those headphones?
Squads, I wanna start out
by saying
both of you
had a challenge today
of making a boy band music video
and you succeed.
But one of you is a loser.
The winner will receive
the Tryphy.
Anyone who holds this
or touches it
will forever walk in greatness.
- I feel the power.
- But do not worry.
The losers do not go home
empty handed.
The losers will be
taking home with them
the case of bulbs
that we had here today on set
that all broke.
So we have to have a winner.
And today's winner
of the '90s boy band
music video
Big Try
is...
the Lost Boys Squad.
Congratulations.
I'm sorry, Dating Squad.
You guys really had
the it factor, you brought it
but we were won over
by the incredible character work
and ultimately,
the great music video
that you all made.
Thanks so much to both squads
for joining us today
and a very special thanks to--
Lance Bass, he's wonderful.
Guys, we'll see you next time
on "Squad Wars"
where we'll be live
from Lance Bass's apartment.
♪ I also love you ♪
♪ And I love you too ♪
See you next time
on "Squad Wars".
♪ We all love you ♪
♪ And we'd like
to offer the chance ♪
♪ For you to love four men ♪